let's go to the phones on a very very
busy news week 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we will
start with our caller from the 3-1 to
area code let's go to our caller from
the 3-1 - hi they read the seller from
Chicago hey how are you good
so I had the question just I had a
thought when I was at the store I see
that these major corporations you know
always ask before you pay you know we
were willing to donate 2 $3 to a good
cause it ends up being a good cause but
it just rubs me the wrong way because
it's like you're a multi-billion dollar
corporation why don't you donate a
billion dollars to this corporation
instead of asking to $3 from people who
already maybe lower middle class middle
class and you know when I talk about it
to people their reaction seems to be
kind of mixed like they're kind of torn
because it is a good cause like the
Children's Hospital yeah
but I I don't get past the fact that
these are still billionaires asking for
2 $3 I totally agree with you and I am
mixed in a sense because I I'm not
saying that the cause isn't a good one
I'm not saying that the issue right
you know childhood cancer is is not an
issue that we should be taking seriously
and and working to solve and you need
money to solve that or hunger for
example but when I go to Whole Foods and
you know that Whole Foods was you know
trying to prevent having to give
employees health care under Obamacare
and all those different stuff and then
they're like hey will you round up your
purchase or give us $1 or $5 for this or
that it's like are you seriously asking
me for that given what you have been
doing but at the same time I don't want
to suggest I don't care about the cause
because I do it is a Rea weird thing and
I think it works on guilt a lot they
want to guilt people into making these
donations they use like you know a child
hospital which usually deals with like
cancer and kids and yeah so you feel
torn and you want to donate but at the
same time I feel angry because it's
already like you've taken so much and I
feel like the middle class the poorest
people you know lower class they
shouldn't be putting in more
you know I feel like it's a great cause
then you put in more absolutely you
don't need million dollars let me ask
you Priscilla do you ever do the
donations you know I used to but I feel
like as I got older I think I got
angrier like I just got more cynical
eyes you know and I just I felt like
their care for people is not really
genuine so if I do do donations I do
directly to the organization's versus
going through like you know Whole Foods
or Walmart or anyone who offers like
that that's exactly what I do and you
know part of it is when charities are a
big area of scams and I want to make
sure that not only is the money getting
to the charity but I want to make sure
that the party is also using the money
in a way that's responsible so whenever
I'm asked for any donation and if it's
at the grocery store I just say no thank
you
but if I'm asked on the street or if
someone comes to the door soliciting I
always say listen the way I decide is I
proactively seek out organizations that
share my mission and values and I make a
contribution to them after I've
researched them and those are my
donations for the year I don't like on a
whim throw another five or ten dollars
at this or that thing I think about I
put time into it and that's what I do
that's it and I feel like they've been
doing that a lot with like the hospitals
out to you like from my hospital like
I'm getting a lot of like hey Tony you
know five dollars to this good cause and
it's you guys already charging on and I
like to be seen there and they're still
I mean a girl beyond that then you know
talking about donating to hospitals
given the for-profit private insurance
system that we have it's a mad that's
that's a complete other story for a
different day but very good point
Priscilla I appreciate you calling in
and making it thank you so much for
thinking I called a but I'm a long time
listener but thank you I hope to hear
from you again I appreciate it